un animal triche jamais je les question
que je pose je les pose avec mes mains
directement au corps de l'animal et donc
l'animal ne peut pas tricher bonjour je
suis Sandrine Leblet ostéopathe
animalier et je vais vous parler de mon
métier aujourd'hui
et là je vois qu'au niveau cervicales on
est un petit peu mieux mais c'est pas
encore parfait donc on a encore des
petites choses à travailler
aujourd'hui Sandrine Leblet effectue une
visite de contrôle à Frida cette chienne
qui a été victime de maltraitance c'est
la première fois que Sandrine va la voir
où il y a eu un énorme travail de fait
de sociabilisation d'approche que je
pouvais pas mettre la main dessus elle
était extrêmement peureuse il y a 20 ans
Sandrine Leblet s'est intéressé au
bien-être animal c'est pour cela qu'elle
a choisi le métier d'ostéopathe cette
pratique qui améliore le bien-être et
l'équilibre de l'animal ça m'arrive très
souvent à la fin de la consultation
lorsque le rempli mon compte-rendu
d'avoir l'animal qui vient se coucher à
mes pieds et qui qui pose sa tête sur
mon pied qui s'endort et des
propriétaires qui sont qui sont vraiment
stupéfaits et maintenant c'est le tour
d'optimiste cet ancien cheval de course
qui a subi de multiples blessures à
l'épaule
on va se mettre au soleil là
[Musique]
on va donc faire le test sciatique sur
optimiste tu es prêt optimiste allez on
y va
très bien donc là on a pu voir le
bascule du bassin le document
c'est un petit peu décalé donc voilà
j'en prends note pour la suite si ce
métier était autrefois réservé qu'aux
chevaux il est désormais ouvert à plus
d'espèces
maintenant qu'on a vraiment de très
bonnes écoles d'ostéopathie animale oui
on pratique sur chevaux sur les chiens
les chats bien sûr sur les vaches sur
l'autre fois la gênée étudiante qui qui
me racontait avoir pratiqué même sur une
tortue c'était assez amusant et elle est
ressortie de son tutorat avec les yeux
brillants elle disait géniale
Sandrine Leblet pratique aussi des
séances à Paris et avancer le métier est
en plein développement en France
[Musique]